you
you
you
you
they run welcome welcome I've got the
wrong overlay on how's it going I'm Dave
joined by the real-life version of Alex
chadmarco coins how's it going bud I
should probably turn my mic on otherwise
a really boring stream that's not very
great a review I'm doing I'm doing great
I'm ready to get slaughtered in the war
zone how about you yeah I try to have a
warm-up earlier and I've not won a game
all day so I'm expecting you to actually
carry me I'm gonna change my operator
because if you're gonna play as you I'm
not gonna play as you I won't take
offense if you are great operators if
you want to look at an operator you why
don't you pick my up instead I'm sorry
what if you want to look at an operator
why don't you pick you can pick mine
since you have to look at me throughout
the entire game oh I think I've already
got your your choice highlighted so yeah
let's go with the captain I can't I
can't blame you the captain with the
really over-the-top anime gun I love
that he'll never see you coming Captain
Price likes anime confirmed oh so how do
you feel like you're a prepared the real
warzone combat with your battles
background in in college you itself all
of those skills are translated from the
character to the player nothing could
prepare me for this unless I played 40
hours a week like everyone else I can't
really do that any time soon I will
always be woefully unprepared sadly
well you know what the win isn't there
what's important with a minute we're
what's important is we're raising a
little cash for charity as much as we
can support both black lives matter in
the covert 19 relief so if if if we fail
then its failure for a good cause right
you know it's just it's a comedy show
for good cause that's okay well you're
choosing the drop then even chat you let
us know firm things are too loud or sort
it all out I don't know why you can't
kill people in the startup now there's
this really weird thing of I just did
you can you can do executions they get
back up
my captain price just plug the dude any
and he got up like it was nothing okay
tell you what
tell you what we'll do is for every kill
I get in war zone today I'm gonna donate
but but a buck in a pot and donate all
the end so that's that's a motivation
for getting as many kills as possible
I'll do the same I'm gonna start it look
at that well they go chat now you have
to every time I get killed I'll donate
five dollars so I'm just gonna get you
in a Jeep and get you off this since the
C then Julie for a good cause okay cool
I just won't open my parachute ever okay
let's go I said it's a weird circle
let's go to the promenade
or as close to as a I have to please
this week's eggnog I'm not going to get
you a pizza anywhere if I did it'd be a
nicer pizza than that come on and all
I've got is a gun from like this century
prior yeah you're gonna have to keep
killcount the FAL sorry John the foul I
can drop you the foul I'll take anything
once my game stopped service minimizing
what I say and good you started with a
great weapon and I was just greedy and
picked up oh oh it was already there I
can't as in the ground rock and roll oh
you take it it's right well it starts
scavenging this building get something
UAVs ready that's that's illegal
and I got technicals jeez it looks
dangerous every time I press the tab
button my games minimizing which isn't
ideal
so I'll just never never look at the
main venturi be fine just don't just and
I don't ask you to drop anything
this should be an adventure
okay we get to be seen if it's
successful successful one people asking
if you're good at the war zone I'm just
gonna tell them yes and we're the best i
pew of it were the best that I know turn
the page
Adam J I'm a big fan of a lot of rounds
I can I can respect that spray-and-pray
take it I'm not a good shooter wait a
second
your username as it would sniper in it
and you just even make a movie about
being a sniper I know the cool thing
about being a sniper in a movie is you
don't have to hit anything it's great
when I saw um saw that movie you were
sharing
I couldn't eat you might have heard full
I couldn't get out of my head you know
Bradley only from Bon Appetit they're
always references the original sniper
movies I do
here's that catchphrase is one shot one
kill sighs okay ins me thought of that I
should rewatch those alright do we have
goals we have objectives I'm just
following you current objective is to
survive I'd say I drop them drop some
but if I hit to have my games gonna blow
up so well we figure that out as we go
winging it people will get it fruit
cause exactly
I'm hoping people take pity on us and
match our donation or death incentive
there's a tiny stubby gun that's purple
so rocker box someone's asked can you
say something from the campaign was your
favorite line from the campaign the
trailer way you were enriched introduced
was pretty strong one line after action
that was my favorite scene and the
campaign was was the goodbye scene with
Alex and Farah he goes off to make his
heroic sacrifice I did him in this is my
favorite line I know it's short and
sweet thank you give me goose bumps
again I'm trying to try to be pro gamer
here man I got very emotional watching
that myself when I already knew was
happening any pixels were there pixels
that meant something to me okay oh we're
getting shot by an RPG I think yeah
respired okay
I think it's East from the houses oh oh
good I've seen a crossbow as well I see
if you can drop down an hour oh there's
some assassin after us do you know where
they are have you got the kill cam I did
not even see where that came from as
usual guy right under me I gotta watch
Gulag strategy videos cuz
I got be G they they Ares
they were in them at building under us
and they shot you in the bum through the
window - yeah unfortunately my favorite
thing to do is a spray paint all the
people read so they're easier to see no
I got riddled are you still alive see
when you come back so I warm up hot
start sixty first out of how many 65 I
broke up date available one entire piece
of armor do you need to do a quick
update or are you you get out come on
why would it do this no I'm not doing it
as if ecology doesn't update enough if
we had to donate like a buck per
gigabyte there needed updated I think we
might have real salt it would be world
peace thank you so much everyone who's a
doughnut into these wonderful wonderful
causes that's like two deaths apiece now
so somebody attract keep count my
current objective is to you I want that
really cool endscreen when you go off in
the helicopter Oh super badass is flying
away as Captain Price and he's got this
super long anime covered Odin strapped
to his chest looking really badass to
see this yeah the only time I see the
end screen is when awesome gamers tend
to be on social media watching a that's
cool watching highlights
I will admit as much as I'd like to say
that I'm good at video games I've not
actually clutched out a warzone when
it's my secret shame
I have not either and it'll probably
never happen it's live from when battle
Royales with a with a hot thing I've won
I've got one win in every battery I'll
game warzone Aluna eyes on everything
everything you know so multiplayer in
general is completely new for me in this
game this one's probably got one of the
strongest campaigns as well as the
strongest multi players in recent years
have you gotten any predictions about
the next quarter GE there's rumors of
cold war and I've been seeing the videos
flying around which I'd be super hyper
focused then did you play the black ops
campaign one I have not I've only played
Call of Duty the original trilogy and
those were all campaigns I liked d-day
landing the I read one
yeah I've literally never played
multiplayer till it started distributing
on Twitch in like late March how do you
eat it says the ultimate new
if you want a good squad a duty campaign
uirr
yeah you should play black ops the first
one black ops I've heard I mean that's
it's full of like CIA Cold War like
injuried think oh there's a is something
like the captain prices in nearly every
ecology be game that's let's go to these
hangers blurs actually yeah the original
trilogy you play as we didn't play as
you you meet is like obviously long
distant grandfather or something right
but same same mustache same gruffly
voice yeah yeah in a cookie or right
where the devil are you
oh there you are that's great timing
to stop in power rounds there's a guy
Oh in the distance big hangar thank you
has any bad intentions though no it's
another box in here hey over on times
making it nice and easy to donate even
dropping the link in there for you what
legend is oh Jesus I can't get the
stairs who would have thought that
playing on American servers and using
discord and streaming would be a intense
on the old frame rate I'm scanning I'm
just making sure everyone knows my
excuses now see you guys in the roof 340
aircraft control tower I'm above you the
roof and the roof of one of the big
aircraft hangars I think big round roof
I'll got you okay can't see where they
went though but there's a chest under me
oh yeah one of the roof found one I hear
sounds
yeah watch a Malone Arbor in this one
hanger
I guess his friend he's gonna pick him
up a pool this is a bad spot I actually
got a cat again yes there's a guy on my
marker on this roof there was Captain
Price that put a hole through
oh yeah he's still up there you see the
gold marker right he's down again yeah
okay his teammates in the building with
him so he's keeps going down I reckon we
just push him goes through the green
stripy building and caused some trouble
more about the guns
mr. just click people in the head and
there they'll fall over
that's how I am that's how I like break
down shooter games when people ask me
for advice so just click just click
heads alright they might run away
cowards
it's not very captain price of you you
know it's a good idea in their part
Retreat retreat when you see us is that
also way of just saying please leave us
alone oh no he's on the roof I take it
back inside cabbage this is a brave
brave brave man oh they're both on the
roof you have to cover me
oh no Captain Price says I've taken
effect on you give it a shot I've not
got the best cover in the world but I
don't think they know you're here thank
you
yes on the roof cracked one hammer
hammer this truck is a great friend
[Music]
victory no matter what you have you got
more than me
Hey return fire God will turn effective
fire keep their heads down all right so
if you if you see someone the GU like
hold T and use one of the sprays and if
you can like hit them with a colorful
spray it makes it a little bit easier to
to see them
that might be now I'm a I'm shooting
folk in the face I suppose that's killed
so I believe in you you in the gulag my
god it just flashback happens to the
best of us I literally flashbang whistle
I didn't know I had tactically yeah it
just takes a few seconds to actually let
you use it you can do my best to show
pee but obviously as people can see I'm
not exactly a shroud yeah by the skin of
my teeth
actually no it's always a faster stop to
you pistol then reloading right as the
old saying goes
rest in peace soap you are a few
thousand dollars short of the redeploy
it's all right let's make some cash
money when I wipe some squads
I've got hundred rounds with someone's
name on it
I'm gonna ping the redeploy station just
so you know you can't afford me have a
cluster minder of how broke you are yeah
well I came across the $300 yeah that's
what I've got to my name of the minute I
think the most powerful weapon I can
have with the minis is cheap and it's
camouflage and no one's actually gonna
see me coming it's the perfect weapon
there's actually a guy behind me on an
ATV he might be chasing me
feel like you would win that fight ATB
versus it's the machine and I want to
use against it oh no don't go view on
the rock I need to be able to see D well
it's half my bullets gone
[Music]
they're gonna they're gonna they gonna
have to taste Piper
oh there is I seen him I seen him
see on the other side of that wall just
there alright and 143rd what's the
stream yeah buts them rate and improving
their alright I can actually restart
mycology so I can fix this bug so I can
have to invite you back to a party but
you shouldn't take a couple seconds
a shame I was very proud of actually
spraying them off the Jeep off the ATV
though so at least they're gonna be
walking from now on good yeah good move
that's what I was scared of Ethan I saw
someone I saw those guys notice my
vehicle and I felt the RPG being aimed
at me
the c-4 in the middle of the air I
wasn't gonna I wasn't about to go down
like that
I'll give it as good as you get
and since we're in the pause and then
action now is the perfect time to share
the love and get donating and yeah of
everybody I'm reading I'm reading the
the stream on my twitch channel so I see
some great good friends in the chatroom
get those links flying around you know
whatever whatever you fancy Cove in
nineteen relief or black life doesn't
matter both those links are there every
buck you donate is a bit powers chat and
I up enough to perhaps gain the top 20
today it is it's like armor plate every
dollar let me the ultimate paisa win
right you having a contactless credit
card to get some other place we put it
right in our vest and cash Texas I mean
I think turn it over to charity money
would if you had big wads of cash like
comedy levels like movie heat levels of
cash in your chest I think that would
stop bullet well depending on the bullet
bags I'm on line Jonas shoot me an
invite leave get can't it's a house you
know he said that you're the sniper
movie it was great oh well thank you
yeah I have a new 30 pictures sniper
movie it was yelling at me to update and
I might have X did I click the button a
week and I we can do that real quick
okay I feel before I watch you only
sniper movie I should watch the oh geez
again just so just give them justice you
know yeah the original is so grab that
left such a proud profound impression on
me growing up Tom Berenger in the
opening of that movie and a full ghillie
suit coming out of the shrubbery as a
helicopter I suppose I use down you
better do it 360 noscope in your movie
yeah oh this is a short update yeah
you're right okay yeah it's any of you
maggots not it's not one of those awful
like our new seasons out you get to play
in three days yeah um but yeah there's
movies called sniper assassins and it
drops tomorrow and me and Tom Berenger
father and son running around facing a
new threat I want to see you pick up
every sniper iPhone that horribly inept
to make sure we're
yeah I'm talking about Call of Duty's
game is so big but it's so beautiful it
also makes my PC really angry at times
yeah it is I feel like I can I should
expense like an air conditioner for my
room whenever I play Call of Duty fans
kick up the rash like okay in the sauna
now you're a sniper somebody asks so
named every sniper rifle that's your
challenge now as an actor I go by the
really heavy one the sort of heavy one
because those things are heavy
it's crazy I think most most people
haven't picked up like a 50 Cal yeah
hyper rifle but those things are long
and the weight is it's front loaded like
towards the you know the barrel so it's
quite quite awkward to be sprinting
around with those things everyone should
have the experience of trying to do a
wind sprint with a 40-pound sniper right
say we're talking about we do it all the
time in Cota GV that's basically really
cool um yeah senior in shoot me an
invite and we'll drop back in alright
I'm in but since you're the man in
charge I am going to oh yeah you might
have to just reappear online so I can
grab you yeah a little lag here there we
go
there is right go you can join my Kim I
do love that yo your icon is a little
you jump into the screen as well alright
purse on a ground or not there wasn't
that's just brand that I'm not drinking
while I am drinking a beer but it's just
ginger beer aiming responsibly okay
Tom's gonna instantly be jealous now cuz
it's like one of his favorites and he
can't get in America I don't think oh
really yeah such as the culinary exports
let's be fair I don't think I'd hit any
of my shots if I was drinking real big
boy beer so it's pretty for the best not
I'm hitting my shots now say that for
games like that like finesse games like
darts or even shooting if you have like
one to two drinks actually he presses
your nervous system enough that you just
an excuse when you play darts you
watched the arnold schwarzenegger
documentary where he says that he when
he was getting super massive for his
first films he was drinking beer
I never heard that no yeah it was the
strategy behind that cuz it's I think it
was just that it was just easy way to
get carbs and at the time calories I
think the line is since he's talking
about the gym weightlifting scene and
how they drink milk
he was like now with wit they don't be
see in my party yes if you drop in I can
always drop back out if we've lost you
well the game starting anyway so
hopefully you are back in but I did just
hear a random deaths out
there's a flash that can I have my knee
I think the I think the update wait wait
what the as there's there's some haunted
things happening in the in the game
right now I just had like two characters
inside of each other all right I'm gonna
I'm gonna restart the game cuz that was
I was extremely cursed you're still in
the the party there right you see my
Captain Price hanging around with his
big-city gun I see almost graphics
working stop my screen going silly game
spots been streaming all last night too
or is this the first week of a couple
weeks now you haven't we've been going
for a while now this is that it's the
first one that I've done because it's a
lot of it's in the the US side but the
pro gamer that I am the grab me for
college you do they yeah we've been am
in going long time raising money black
lives matter and covert 19 which people
can generously donate right now if they
feel so inclined would be much
appreciated and yeah we've still got a
long long way to go it's like it's like
the instead of the the yearly gaming
event being III we thought we'd uh
during a one for some good artistic
means you'd have to go to a LA and I
don't put on twenty heroes by browning
in myself in chicken wings every year as
well
now wasn't he three last year for you
know some of the sneak previews they
revealed of our game and it was first
time I've ever gone and it was more so
fun just the installations for cyberpunk
and elder scrolls I was so fun is the
first time I I went it was yeah an
extreme stream bucket list moment right
what was that what was I record 42 43
point three or forty third the less okay
go 43 to Pete do you question in the
chat do you plan on doing any more video
games voice acting I gotta be honest I
love it the process was so fun
people are so cool I think what I
noticed right away especially with
infinity water and Activision was people
making these video games
[Music]
is there another franchise I'm taking
these questions from chat forum no I
actually this clever think about but I
dream of waking says if you could appear
in another video game I'm assuming that
means if you've got to pick what would I
would you pick
I mean the Ford goes away I would love
to have a voice I've been playing since
Manila
and I don't get to play as much anymore
but it's always been one of my all-time
favorite games so would it be alliance
ahold then no more sure for the Alliance
baby the good guys although everyone's
justified us now you played North
Warcraft briefest of times in my life
but I was I was in the Alliance
I tried playing for like
doesn't speak to myself alright let's
say I go to the lumber mill cut up some
woods as well as tools
I might fix my computer as a one
gentleman right there I love that you
call them hostels and I call that call
them a gentleman there's no guns please
and bereft of weaponry right now
see lamo right well he regrets coming
into my lumber mill switching to
personals faster reloading there's gonna
be another guy around here somewhere um
and I think he's angry that I killed his
friend so keep your eyes open there's
like an old SAS line that I think I got
from a game or a movie which doesn't
exactly make a lot of sense but I always
thought it sounds cool I said when you
when you're fighting you've got be like
milk yeah keep cool don't freeze weird
like me pasty British boy says it
doesn't sound nearly as cool as if like
if Captain Price said it you'd be like
yeah milk I understand I need to get
some shields I'm coming to you yeah just
looking for a few plates
it's so clear and I'll give it to
another player yeah a bounty target so I
reckon we should head west someone asked
is a Barry Sloane just as badass in real
life great guy great sense of humor it's
such an amazing job with price he had
the hardest job you know price has been
around for a long time he's a favorite
fan favorite and there's that's a lot of
pressure
what's weird now is that and I mean this
in I've seen that complimentary way but
I've forgotten what old price sounds
like to me now prices prices it's this
voice that's cool he did a great job of
paying tribute to the old price but also
made it his own he's such a great guy
oh guys below us one downed on the rail
railway oh he's very dead sorry that
means they interrupt you what you saying
alright so help yourself to the garbage
on the ground that these these lots at
ninety two rounds yeah he shot he shot
on me didn't find their mark I reckon we
can his car again in a circle
don't I get a spiced up by the but a gas
don't drive or shotgun I really wish I
could pull off a boonie hat like that
oh wait if you if you want a cool
vehicle skin we are we're gonna ditch
this vehicle
yeah now this this is a vehicle skin
look at the look at the Bay in the back
oh you can jump in the back that's right
I won't crash I'm a great driver
it looks like someone's been respawn as
was Valley fairway away
now it's beautiful but about this truck
is that it's so like over that it
circles all the way background becomes
Cova again like they're gonna be looking
for army guys no one's gonna be looking
for someone heading to comic-con
exactly
that's where we good I was wrong they
will shoe us we out oh there's a guy on
the roof ahead of us that roofed it that
we're just heading fast
tagged times
I say we ditch our truck it's a building
in here that's got a good vantage point
we should head into Oh big ol machine
here if that that's a fancy you never
stops you in but really like a sniper
rifle right now well there's a I can see
a guy but he's so far away and don't
think I'm gonna hit him hey Gregory
hello Ivan oh yeah they're gonna truck
the driving away you better run
Oh
tagging them up 5-10 minutes to reload
where can we go to the the loadout that
they left over see if there's any goods
for us laying about oh oh yeah he's
right near me as well oh this might be a
mistake that's me
blue on blue yeah I can hear his pal I'm
very scared all of a sudden joined you
he's in this building safety Falls for
that oh yeah we should spend some of
that cash money yeah let's head to the
circle head to like that gold marker oh
I think I just saw someone I'm gonna
gonna need backup I think oh yes I'm on
someone six Oh knocked him somebody
there you go Oh sir just came off come
up over out of the river and I saw that
guy and you shooting a machine guy I'd
lie if I said that hasn't caught caught
me out too
we tried
oh this isn't where you park someone's
been near here so I'm gonna do I'm gonna
put a mine under it and hope that
somebody comes back to their car they go
double Mines
oh I see a guy a roof guys moved
oh yeah he's a
I found him don't eyes well in a way I
should be able to drop your feet
if I can't escape here was a guy
parachuting in if you come to me and
I'll drop you dropped your stack next to
me if you need it oh they're back the
friends you made on the roof or back
ones down yeah come to me I just dropped
some on the ground
they were on that roof I sit so they
would have moved by now though
I downed one but okay I grabbed that
Hammond yeah yeah yeah I'll see you in a
C in a week thank you for your donations
chat it's very kind of you
much appreciated we are gonna be
donating a buck for every kill I get so
if anyone's in the game let me just let
me kill you okay I don't I don't know
where those guys are now and I'm scared
yeah there's one nearby those are supply
choppers I recognize you yeah get to get
up this hill reposition
all right I'm long plates that's a
less-than-ideal yeah they've left their
little roof nest all again sniped up you
need armor plates and there's a fire
station here if you need plates trying
to see where we go shot from we've got a
little airstrike to call in on I'm after
there if we find them
yeah it was definitely a sniper around
but you don't head this way
I feel that we might might give us away
shoot this this one
although then again I haven't got that
many bullets so maybe I should save them
to shoot the bad guys danny mills rachel
matin and nicole Clemmie thank you for
your donations that is very cash money
of you I think this big Soviet looking
building has our name on it we should
head up there this one cheeky little
advantage see if we can see any bad lads
or got stuck on the door
well with be in our previous record
already so not to jinx us oh this guy
here either Oh yep there is he's dead
got you homie
let me ask how do you feel about your
ecology performance I feel yeah little
nervous jumping into a such a like a big
franchise so the originally just
audition for gruff army man I shot guy
in the bum there's a guy below us
there's also go parachuting in above us
somewhere so keep your eyes on the sky I
think that's what that flare that means
right oh yeah I see and I'm taking a
couple of potshots not sure if they're
gonna hit you know
it's worth a go
but his pal was below us I see you go
there Oh God
missed him in the chest instead of the
face we might have to get moving my
friend
that's not fun you there was a guy in
that building like 100 meters away
Arvin says he thinks your sound is
extremely cool so oh behind us on our
six there's two of them Nellie we have
an impressive angle on me let's be fair
so we're gonna win the ghoul I can get
right back in it I see you turn around I
hope not
you might be bright red knocking
knocking some of the rough stuff
although we are jumping into like
late-game with like no loop oh hell
I jumped directly on two guys I didn't
see them from the sky they just saw me
float on in and rinsed me well i'm
spectating you now so I'm expecting big
things
oh lucky mate yeah sneaky sneaky man 20
pairs down 23rd look at us
hole 20 slots higher than we were so it
look at us wait yeah it was the power of
the big anime truck I think that's very
true
after that everything went up I think
we've got good guns we've got some kills
or you had loads cash money
so what is it sixty five players per
game four teams yeah in a game it'd be
150 and have been a match right
understand the game so unless somebody
[ __ ] yeah right did that myself a
third twenty third out of 75 that's just
sounds like I should retire a passing
grade if you call it surely up third
your class
every the the ecology gods will take
pity on us and we will watch out a win
but rich is taking keeping count of our
kills for us keeping us honest good
right good
Thank You Kim for the donation that's
very very cool of you
much appreciated no matter who you were
you want to support black lives matter
over 19 it's all all going to good
causes you get comes up from me and
Captain Price
have you got any favorite guns in this
game like if you're I mean it seems like
the machine guns are your favorite after
last round you shred him folks um I I am
the big fan of the PKM but I've been
getting a lot of really great advice
from players and friends you know about
these small machine guns and the a arse
and you know the loadouts
and stuff so molotov is my favourite
diesel I wasn't expecting to go for the
big Russian gun that's for sure yeah
suis fair my favor is the Odin which is
my everyone says Nana it's it's no good
but I tend to use guns that are more fun
than like yeah more effective yeah yeah
like I like the shotguns but you know
unless your shipment pretty much yeah
chain-smoking as a captain price here
best
I don't think Pink Floyd was a smoking
hot one while he was meleeing someone in
the back though he wanted it as a way to
relax
okay
we had a good run at the lumber mill
a strong facial hair in this plane I got
to say let's do the boneyard yeah I've
kind of regret it as soon as I smile
except jumps out the plane so I feel
like I'm committed now
thank you for that tomorrow right
beep little pp19 there was a shotgun
here if you want it this blue building
that's got slugs great Oh like myself
off of a 747 though Oh someone's
someone's a near me I'm scared
coming to you for the emotional and
physical support with guns all right
okay yeah there was someone in one of
the plane bodies I saw an empty box and
panicked at least
we should go towards those gunshots see
all the ruckus is
there's more boxes in here if you're
short of Jean supplies that's good yeah
something tells me we're gonna need that
oh and just like that were rich again
okay oh that's a enemy not up you need
some support my friend
Oh
shoving bits of metal in my chest I'll
be back in the fight in a second mo I'm
a maillis shooting he's one still down
though he got up on top of the plane
oh he's gonna come for me oh I think I
just saw a shadow please I say oh thank
goodness
okay they're dead
oh there's a another team though ah no
bullets let you down no I'm good
let's go on top of the plane same place
the guy was one down up dead both of
them that's another guy here okay
they're all dead okay look at this
absolute gamers what bullets you need
I'm good for now
drop drops a little little something
something there so wants to know if you
have any inspirations for getting into
voice acting or is it just that you had
a really lovely voice and thought yeah
it's er roll with this you know this was
this was an audition that was full face
capture performance capture motion
capture mmm oh wait a minute
there it is the old massive machine Oh
window to that plane if you want to
suppress I've got an RPG with his name
on it
damn I'm the worst shot he's still in
that general area he might have he might
have gone somewhere else when I'm scared
oh there he goes the guy hopped up in
there wrap in the same in the same place
that we're getting shot from in the
highway oh yeah I'm retreating I'm
falling back and get hit marker oh yeah
I see him that near me one's dead you
might need to put a plate in if you've
got some yeah he's still in that same
plane up high it's very her too
sir some right I can't get in without
climbing a ladder you're a grenade you
can throw up there I don't have a
thermite and it seems John powerless
okay yeah he wasn't here cleaning up all
this Oh his friends coming
oh this is not an automatic I know my
friend is be struck back in just dropped
it on the roof over there I'm gonna take
the high ground see if I can't flush him
out a little bit from this hanger yeah
I'm on your flank
you must he must have jumped out so I
can't see him in in that plane chassis
yeah they're his buddies
oh but yeah what I was saying was us in
this game you know it came take you
through my television and film agents
because it was full performance capture
motion capture everything else so uh-huh
the voice-over component obviously is a
big part of it but alex is me and I'm
Alex so they wanted actors hey selling
that roof on the air in the cold market
it's got riot shield coward pickable you
know you you keep them distracted I'm
gonna go get my sniper rifle these guys
are annoying me all right where is my
sniper rifle is alright as I was saying
how they still in that roof oh there's
somebody on the ground now yeah I'm
coming kind of place there with my can't
see them now that one's in so what is in
these planes
oh right by us
if you've got a loadout you want to grab
there's a speck right over over here
yeah mine are all built for like
nominally display okay that's fun I must
admit Richie I'm not the biggest fan of
boneyard so I don't know why I suggest
it is oh what a gamer he went for the
loader thing and another guy that was
dead Oh another person here he crawling
might puke on him I don't think they
know where I'm at that's well you can
regale people with stories well yeah
somebody asked did you know about Alex's
fate when you started yeah you know with
anything so massively Call of Duty is
massive you know people love leaks
people love spoilers so they basically
don't tell us that I think we don't
absolutely need to know and sometimes we
find out things on the day so I didn't
know what was gonna happen Alex but I
was thrilled to get the call in March
when they threw him back in season three
and it was revealed that he survived to
get the gas factory explosion I was
pretty a pretty sick thing to thought it
was also five yeah I was I missed the
shots back
get up Dave you ain't leavin let's be
aggressive
thanks for MAME this guy this war zone
stuff it's pretty fun what I do play it
I really enjoy gets your blood flowing
right yeah all right you're on your way
back there's lots of guns on the ground
for you to help yourself too
thank you so much Reverend donut and you
guys are incredible and you're all
helping some very good causes anyway you
can obviously see the links on the
screen so go to any one of those um
donate what you can
would be amazing yeah there's loads of
dead people around here so if you want
to come back over this there's RPGs and
guns and everything grown boy needs
really I want the mp7 this FAL has been
so good good for me I think I'm gonna
keep it let's go oh there is a guy on
our six let's get into a bit of a
vantage point and then we're gonna have
to run a thing
I fell okay here trying it in a circle
if we can the gas might hurt is here I
didn't have my sniper rifle but I
ditched it and I bugger all right it's
guys ahead of us
Oh watch your back man doing a flyover
yeah there's two guys in the gas station
ahead of us
bob and weave serpentine regret ditch my
sniper rifle now um you can ping a by
station isn't it one day by I can buy it
back again see if I can get that without
getting shot well there's lots of guns
on the ground still so yeah needs to
hide somewhere you're the best Dave I
got you homies buddy save you from the
Gulag of shame oh I see
noun 1 there's some on the ground near
the trucks and the burnout car ok there
is a sniper now yeah shooting us yeah I
reckon we should look it you got
something that goes bang got 30 bullets
rifle what do you need this guy's right
behind us they're gonna they're gonna
give chase at some point we're by that
truck yeah since I saw his legs how we
get some guns oh we've got what actually
we haven't got too long yeah I see them
they're over here by the fire station
I'm taking like a PE bullets there was a
truck the other side of this wall why
you come to me we'll see if we can get
back into the zone without getting
murdered
all right I've dropped a plate box you
need to grab some plates before we move
on thank you for the donation Monica
very appreciated very generous absolute
legend all right you're I'll play it up
let's all shut the backs on the back oh
no all right I'm in cover if you can
grab me real quick yeah this is Oh
everyone's gonna be hiding now all right
let's hope like an clutch at school like
Danny you still might be in it although
the sky I'll take notes then take notes
for the last spray captain price is a
distraction
Oh 16 not too shabby huh
that's a kill heavy game too
I mean I even got a couple of people
that's how you know you shred him people
up in the last game with that big LMG at
least we can say every match has been an
improvement we've gone up the ladder
each and every one first one was Langley
knock the rust off no it was it didn't
have any any anime skins I was there
what gave us a parish wait
there's plenty of photo drop drop in
there F's for respect I appreciate that
reading my like challenges which I never
pay attention to yeah minutes of
challenge enough just to stay alive in
this thing so I'm feel like yes to that
and then I can deal with get X number of
headshots into the desk I uh my new
challenge is to grab 15 piles of cash
just Hoover a lot I I had loads of money
in there in that last one it was 40
flush do
that's the problem we didn't spend
enough go spend money to make money
well thank you for noticing coughing cat
yeah yeah is I mean I'm happy with
without with the size considering how
like how rough boneyard was we got it's
like four fights in one ok can we do
better what do we finish sixteenth first
yeah yeah
maybe
a few more cracks in this see if we can
get in the top 15 that's the goal some
graduate earlier now the over what you
gave and there's emotional support as
well that's a lot of it morale all right
let's go can we drop this end of airport
let's go spicy although we have actually
been here Shawn Jarvis wants to know
about more about your sniper movie he's
got two wonderful young sons together Oh
more about the sniper movie well I've
done I've done five there's eight total
and the franchise play Brandon Beckett
of the lead son of a legendary sniper
Thomas Beckett played by Tom Berenger
what else
it's military action so many pictures
they seem to do well around the world
which is really cool it's you know we've
made eight movies over the past 25 years
and you know people always look forward
to the next one so we're trying to catch
up to the Fast and the Furious franchise
there's something about like it's it's
in games as well and there's um there's
an attraction to like things revolving
around snipers I think it's because
people consider it like an elite thing
and it's a mystique around it hey wait
it's crazy because I read somewhere then
you know getting through Sniper school
has a higher washout rated like baby
seals I could be wrong there but I
remember watching documentaries reading
so much stuff about it it is not easy to
become a sniper in any capacity yeah and
even just it's like it's not just
pulling a trigger I have to do like a
trigonometry and maths and you've in
your head exactly all the field craft
Clockwerk it's just stuff is really very
intensive when I was a kid I was radians
gonna to be shooter shooter yeah yeah I
got to play a pretty nasty soldier in
Vietnam on the TV show shooter USA the
adaptation for television and like a
Vietnam flashback rocking a fake
mustache pretty gnarly character
definitely a bad guy well somebody's
asking you about your plants I did say
I'd like a poison ivy so it's not real
very very very low-maintenance green
thumb yeah I was telling day before we
started the stream that I don't I don't
have like a backdrop yet before
streaming so I'm just kind of like
plants are nice you're gonna go all
green screws it's nice for the head of
cars if you hit someone with the rotor
blades they turn to paste Wow just a
nice jelly jam yeah
oh there's someone on the ground
shooting us by that green tent see him
back where is he
green tent just below 10 yeah Oh
Wow see I mean I don't know the tens I
wasn't huh most of it like some kind of
achievement
all right let's well we'll stay in the
chopper then basically like an old
Vietnam Huey Oh as a vehicle blurs right
you shoot in Michigan we're chasing the
vehicle in front in front
halli animals have two bullets Oh either
try to kill it with that chopper or get
me to a place where I can get bullets
gonna be useless fight I've tried not to
hit them rocks you're just chasing this
guy around oh yeah he's scared did you
hit him I saw blood just wrap that thing
around to tell a light pole yeah I heard
bullets left I was trying to line up a
shot of the driver and I just couldn't
you were definitely hitting him I saw I
saw blood I did I had 30 bullets invite
my LMG though that's the play we need to
turn it into like a vietnam style huey
those deer right to your right and
throwing rocks in left left left behind
right now there is
how did I not kill him he's in the
middle bit good I'm not good at the
gulag so much pressure in the gulag
right my heart rate just oh just every
time Oh looks not healthy punched in the
head oh my lord we're all the way back
words asks funny eerie seeing yourself
in a game I suppose getting the shot all
the time and executed and grown in the
ground yes getting blown up and tossed
around like a rag doll is always a
little bit morbid but you know I know
it's just a game so I don't get too too
traumatized
take it personally know this it is funny
that when you play like 6v6 like
shipment and you know all my friends and
stuff they're you know very flattering
and they all play as Alex so it's like a
gang of six Alex's and there's just dead
Alex's all over the ground like yeah
it's gonna be something you go to bed
one night after too much cheese you go
to the line of red line right thinking
about shippment full of Alex exactly we
obviously didn't beat our record in that
one but that one was a good one good
vibes to it you know that was tOA's
which he caught off game off game
sometimes you don't need to see the
victory screen to feel like a winner I
think the actual helicopter shows was
was I was the one that was that was all
the victory I need you to be honest
I keep your eye on what Trump is then
yeah you can we get you in washing with
loads bullets a helicopter and they just
like answers we should play like old
Vietnam music Bob's now yeah I paint it
black let me gunner for Symphony for the
devil blasting out with your shoe I'm
into it I like this plan get that the
cute anime skin for it though yeah
that's very good unlock that for your
helicopter it was a very game
Battlefield Bad Company 2 there's one of
the battlefield that came with my xbox
but I've not played I think I I played
on 360 but in Battlefield Bad Company 2
and there was a Vietnam expansion pack
for it and the helicopters came with
speakers that would play like ride of
the Valkyries or fortunate son actually
pay for the rights for the songs and you
could just fly around in yeah all tuned
style or Full Metal Jacket and stuff
here we go
probably change your skin
yeah why is that you happen to go the
big diaper helmet now I was treating
Alex so bad they can end up at the gue
life let's just head to the gulag
straight away in the corner
your land in this village get some guns
get the big anime truck and then we're
gonna head into victory you're being
hunted
do you hear you annoyed I am yeah and
the left side your screen it should say
that you're at this contract on you or
something you know bring the ruckus
leave my LMG my objective is to protect
you well there's some LNG but it's armor
though how many how many bullets you
rock in the LMG I've got a hundred all
right wait we're gonna instead of being
slightly Valkyries helicopter we'll do
like mounted machine gun truck
look at that beautiful picture you get
in the back and you're spraying people
okay
school
it's okay where we're going we don't
need scopes
we just did Victor's yeah pointing click
click heads
I know the bad guys out there now
well screenshot crashed when I said I'm
a good driver
I see some on the bridge
ah hell nah I mean this thing's what
I've seen a circle of a tugboat but
where we're going for it you might be
able to mount your gun on the front of
it as well if you stand up oh yeah fill
em in
oh it's you by the trees by the tree I
can't live out just keeping his balance
it's the right panic-inducing
he's in the building yeah I'm here with
him he's in front of me oh I see if he's
on that he's on the outside of the
building
yeah he's gotta be so extremely
extremely upset yes he couldn't get in
the window yeah every time you guys the
window you shot him and he fell back all
fair attractions still pretty in a good
shape so I'll just tell ya backup strats
work you know those guys that's gonna
come for their revenge
I hope so hey it's a bullet I can drop
you like a hundred
and I'm that's funny if I can see
okay now we're talking the outside every
truck is lives on
Thomas can't believe you just strike
fear in all players you just killed your
own dress coming
coughing that I say window funny was a
guy oh well you can't take the truck
inside so we can't fight anyone that's
indoors
well there's a guy to the left left now
Park you up left side to hug this huh
get the wheel will for dear life while I
reload literally a turret
they can barely see that guy
attacked him a couple times at least
wasted or not really sure
have you got any armor plates or ubu out
oh I've got no extras oh alright let's
head into this building you might be
able to find some some more head naptha
of the rope thank you again for your
donations chat raising money for yes oh
there is a big LMG on the roof you want
to donate there the links in there are
the places to go
anything you can spare it's very cash
money of you okay I've got sniper rifles
I'm hoping I see some yeah Oh someone's
gonna be dropping in from the sky yeah
there is
aim a couple times that was a delicious
shot I think it was I think was the I
mean it was you it was dressed like you
but I broke his arm when you ran away I
just saw oh yeah I reckon we go for this
loadout droplets ahead of us and then we
go for the helicopter you've got an LMG
loadout or plenty of ammo oh yeah all
that delicious LMG oh my there's a plate
right here I'm not gonna make it to the
roof I am
okay you you go and get whatever loadout
you want to get I'll cover you up here
no one there at the minute anyway
cook women so yeah yeah let me know if
it's that building now all that money
holy yeah sure I know it's ranked epic
okay chopper is this building
oh yeah Oh someone's someone else's got
choppa I think someone else is taking
our chopper that wasn't selling the
reefer chopper theft it's like it's like
horse thieves West no crime Brea okay
alright heading upstairs if I can
remember how oh there's a gun do you I
think under me yeah
I killed him back sometime more gulag
fail hell I'm a Lambo you can't be mad
at that shot oh my god it one hell yeah
alright I'll hold this area down soccer
goalie I just decided to like dive to a
side and not look the other way I'll
hold this area down line back on me and
we'll get some kit gonna head this by
station real quick as well
the Rays guys up on that very tall
building by the way
oh good night mate
as a truck the truck that you know I
heard him running and I was stuck in the
the by men you know you get you get some
gear
he was alone so you might if he if you
bump into him or gets taken I'll try and
win this view like Sola knew now that my
friend don't worry I'll make you proud
I believe in nukes 30 seconds GG I'm
saying that's people so he was near the
I wasn't that by station actually where
he was my actually be oh he was he was
towards that by station the other one so
there might still be gear over there to
your right
should I go to the bus station yeah yeah
the one on your left
yeah that way that might be a some gear
left over or some cash money I know he's
probably almost certainly taking the
cash money oh yeah they're still over
there I would run jump on one of those
barriers jump on that trashcan in front
of you and shoot them from behind
yeah and that trash can no this guy on
your right there
yeah yeah I'll give you an event
advantage point the ground yeah yeah
they were just you're right where that
little Hut was oh jesus gasps right on
me sorry you were just in sick change of
plans
I would grab one of the nave i buy
vehicles maybe this atv you've got a
long way to go
oh that buy station I don't have enough
money do it shoot just a gallon luck
yeah he was near here so yeah if you
keep going forward into you're right
near where the the overhang was
protection I turn around three flashbang
you steer left nine o'clock well guys
the roof and grab the chopper let's see
if you can fly it I can't remember the
stairs I think you can get stuck in the
gas otherwise you need some vehicle and
I should just book it real quick oh yeah
hello shunga man are you yeah follow
that lie on your mini-map and so you
don't get stuck in the gas think yeah
keep running don't don't even leave just
run through the loop
get you in the speck in the circle then
we'll worry about it
I'll keep going keep going you're not
gonna kill him sneak up on him oh he
knows you're there okay good recoil
control as well played though I think
time for one more one more
it should be something we were going to
try in ten will do one more feature as
long as if you can donate to these great
causes of raising money for you very
obliged thank you kindly for trying out
yes thank you very much you mean I know
we're not inspiring you I'm not
inspiring you but my gameplay but
hopefully I'm making you laugh enough do
you feel compelled to donate every for
every chuckle a buck we'll call it a
buckle well might we'll make a pro-gamer
I mean Chad you'll be you'll be on the
eSports new you get no time I'm I'm
looking to get out acting honestly so I
feel like that is a totally viable
career change they should do like like a
celebrity eSports tournament for Call of
Duty for charity and they could have you
and some of the other voice actors and
some other
yeah thanks last Friday they did some
sort of event they do a lot of stuff
with athletes you know athletes mmm love
call of duty which is always really cool
to see have you ever thought of going
into and like just normal like Search
and Destroy lobbies and trying to
confuse people over the microphone her I
almost always mute it are no deeds I
usually all are sore losers you can
definitely go into lobbies and start
puttin on the full Alex charm and sit
and write record the reactions and
stream the reactions that be so funny
haha I probably should
Jeff leach my buddy voices Alex or a
ghost rather likes to likes to mess with
people so you have a whole squad of you
guys that really that really flip some
lids all right now it's see this through
your jump later you're picking when we
drop him
[Music]
you think that matter get promoted by
now I like four-star general price I've
made maybe he turns it down because he
gets stuck behind a desk
let's go Stadium
hello Tabitha we're trying our best to
get some snow kills and some hot content
no winds just yet
with these six bullets we're gonna make
history
between us that's if it was one shot one
kill we still wouldn't have enough to do
the entire match tell you what you need
to find some c4 that's that's the
mission now yeah so I've got drone and
we can put the c4 on the drone and fly
it for someone Thank You Daniel it's a
very kind of you to say welcome
for an LMG there's a real big energy
right there
join the big purple LMG it's in this I
think it's the PKM oh oh it's got a
scope people are in trouble you know
sorry the the mission right now is to
get sea full to the north of us yeah I
heard him coming in but I didn't
actually see um where is coming yeah I'm
just throwing myself through windows
probably a question all tactical choice
were hanging I don't think anyone wants
to live in Vedantic anymore
hey maybe it's a maybe it's
up-and-coming to buyers market oh it's a
guy in his building I just heard his his
little tippy tappy footsteps is one dead
avenge me yeah I'm in the gulag now he
was in the building got the big just
hunt these guys throw caution to the
wind
I was a horrible gulag well I'm coming
back to you do you know the other guys
is he still around
might have been the other building
as I think my loot would have been I
think it was this one this yellow one
next to me yeah yeah I think is the
stone walls yeah it was this building
where I am I don't know if he's still in
here but this was definitely the spot
well maybe it wasn't I'm all turned
around let me see if there's any loot
lying around that give away his I could
do with one yeah
oh he's in this building I just saw in
the window I just uptown
place up behind this behind the carriage
no legends but they gain my moves i he
instantly went down so I think that was
the guide that we wanted what was
someone want to know what the first
video game you bought was a viewer if
you can remember or at least remember
playing I suppose I mean I was a
Nintendo guy so Nintendo was always my
jam
contrast even we're brothers to those
remotes my favorites nice strong choices
can't find the drone I had in this one
saying my grand plan of action was to
get find you some c4 we're gonna strap
some c4 to a drone and then just fly it
at someone
maybe we'll get lucky and find another
one what was a load I drop let's go for
that just to the east
hopefully no one's watching me come on
give me that sniper rifle back there we
go helicopter above us we may as well
give it a good old college try
scared and why do you need the load-out
review who your kid up right sweet let's
rock and roll
guns do you have any sniper rifle ammo
spare if you hit tab and then you okay
shotgun AR LMG launcher sniper thanks
bud I'll I'm on a roll play he was a
sniper to the hills well there's a guy
in the sky I mean I'm no way gonna hit
this guy but it's fun to try
I'm hoping we have we break our pb's
this one I can go in for right so that's
our current standing yeah 33 I don't
know if I can climb up that no that's
back where we came from the gunfire
think I think keeping the high ground
would be for you
that'd be that'd be the strategy Captain
Price would go for our record our boy
another big gunshot that's really eerie
when you can just hear shots rile ray I
know I own again this time Oh someone
can see us I see you I can see from up
here
it's got the creepy tower creaking
yes indeed thank you thank you so much
for everyone who's he's donated their
hard cash to some good causes in their
time for for hanging out with us
it's very appreciated yeah it's back
down that hill I reckon we head this
other building
the two-story stone one
speed demon i was like oh my god am I
gonna am I gonna get crushed it yeah I'm
gonna head in here
I can hear the bad lads but I can't see
the bad lads
turn the safe sound at least I can see
bullet traces and the distance to the
southeast let me go see if I can see
anything through the the big scope human
now it's a piece of rock I thought was
it it's a piece of wood just shaped like
a person
what oh god there's a guy right next to
us no I just heard you blow up and I was
like okay I'm trying to turn a flank
background towards you if you come
around I don't know I just heard a pop
hide him by the tree and he stood up
there I panicked threw a grenade and run
away as the tactically sound thing to do
but now it's time to go up there and
boolean someone's tracking us oh so you
know he's dead oh there's another man in
here
instead I need some plates you got any
spare plates no worries
find some more yeah I just dropped that
help yourself if that's the kind of
thing you want to play with oh you
bugger yeah they're in the fence
container area two of them heading to
the base station
unlucky 19 still top 20 heartbeat sensor
hell well I think we I think we played
very well thank you so much for joining
us I'm sorry we couldn't get a win under
our belts but I think that was a I
respect for months you something the goo
like no okay yeah well yeah thank you
thank you for joining us but it's it's
been great playing with you that was a
lot of fun well have secured a finger to
maybe we should make this a routine
Dave's Dave's lessons of ecology with
Chad please let's go and yeah it makes a
point at a time
thanks everyone for for donating thanks
for picking around very cool
we've got loads more coming this week so
if you can spare your time spare your
donations hugs and kisses and we'll see
you again soon thank you everyone
go dark
you